this is a fun one babe we get into
ayahuasca trips wow chippendales yes uh
iconic supermodels behind the scenes of
practical joker stuff that's exactly
right and a crazy slide that adults
almost get killed on a battery park city
it's amazing and i'm telling you you're
going to want to you're going to want to
watch this episode you're also going to
want to watch
especially weshee my comedy special on
netflix
that's it then babe yeah because i i got
dates coming up in providence uh in the
first week of july at christiecomedy.com
if you want to see it and at the end of
august i'm on the road at in los angeles
at the bray empire improv christy
comedy.com you've got more dates babe
june dates syracuse rochester milwaukee
minnesota hampton beach and foxwoods
july dates vegas boulder colorado
phoenix seattle portland and
vancouver all at salvocountercomedy.com
right
[Music]
babe don't now afraid don't be ashamed
don't hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
hey baby
my love must be the kind of blind love
[Music]
i
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
hey babe
for
you
this is a good song to start with yeah
because guess what babe tonight going to
rails in the city
iconic new york city italian eatery
rayos babe you've been there what do i
order i'm trying to stay healthy play
this tonight they'll come out and sing
it tonight do you ever go no so it's
small have you ever seen it
uh no i didn't want to google it if you
don't know rayo's which is in is it
harlow spanish spanish harlow 16th i
think it's on it's in latinx harlem
we're trying to be progressive it's in
latinx harlem and it is the probably i
would say i'm not saying it's the best
restaurant but i would say it's the most
iconic it's an iconic restaurant so like
they don't take reservations and you
have to know someone to be old able to
eat there got it so someone has to know
somebody to give you the table they i do
they only do one or two seatings at
night there's only about
maybe maybe 20 tables in it it's pretty
small so i have to be there at seven
what if i get there at 7 30 can i not
get seated what's the rules here well
you're going with a big shot but i i
mean i i no it's not like that because
what do you mean seating explain that so
like they
seat there's only two seating so if like
there's a seven o'clock seating and then
like a ten o'clock seating so you have
you can't stay there and hang out you
will you they i think they gotta turn
over the road that's still the way they
do it they turn over the room i think
or maybe if no one has the table for the
whole night you can stay as long as you
want people like have
dibs on the tables is how i was
explaining to it did you go to the seven
o'clock
showing i've been over the years i
luckily uh fortunately i i my friend's
dad has a very big connection with it so
over the years i've gone like a handful
of times it's great food it's great
there's no there's like no menu like
they oh they they bring out the food you
don't wanna come out there like what are
you feeling tonight you know and then
they have what if i say have high
cholesterol high blood pressure they'll
probably tell you
they don't care about that yeah they
don't care about that it's old-school
italian
it's like you know i mean it's it's
actually the place itself it's it's
iconic looking but it's nothing fancy
it's actually like it looks like a very
old it has a lot of character inside
right a lot of uh it's it's like green
walls with all these old pictures and
picture frames on the walls right and
you know the tables are small and
everyone's right on top of each other um
and frank pellegrino who used to be the
proprietor or the owner or whatever of
pellegrino water no okay but he was
probably just as wealthy he has since
passed unfortunately he used to be the
fbi agent on the sopranos
wow really yeah and now his son which is
a frank jr i believe
and other other family members running
and his son frank is was running the
vegas outpost which is different that's
like making it because there was a rails
in la i was in l.a and i was like i
skipped it i said
i'll go to real
the real wrayers all go to know that
and then also the bartender was there
for like 50 years his name was like
johnny vests because he only wore vests
and he passed recently so i'm going to
kind of the rails but it's not it's lost
some of their
kind of the icon i don't know if it's
lost my friend just called me to go too
and we were trying to set it up why
don't you go to let's go tonight i i
can't go tonight i can't go last minute
every time i'm there someone of note is
there it's fun who was there the last
time um i've seen
my friend went and right behind them was
larry david and jerry seinfeld
like sitting in there just the two
sitting in their boots or two of them uh
i've seen pat cooper in there which is
pretty funny that's funny uh i've seen
um
over the years a bunch i mean like a
bunch of of of comedians and celebrities
uh athletes and stuff and things like
that but every time you go in the
kitchen is like old school guys and like
you know a lot of like uh just they knew
my show so that was fun because they
would come out like they get excited
because they probably see everybody but
then when someone comes through that's
like not really whatever but it's a show
they watch you know like they would all
come out of the kitchen and ask for like
picks and stuff which is kind of cool
you know so you can take pics in there
and stuff it's not like like i could
record be like i'm in rails right now
yeah i think i think people do it
because what they used to do if they
still do it they'll like throw on the
radio or the juke or the radio and it's
all songs like the flamingos and people
will like like you know like they'll
sing uh
you know
whoa whoa and the waiters will sing it
no and frank would come and start
singing and then if anybody else is
there that works and they start singing
and then people just get up out of their
seats the whole restaurant sings
together
and then people get out of their seats
and start dancing and everything and
it's only like 40 people in the whole
place did you get up and start singing i
did yeah i did i was like this is
awesome wow yeah we was everyone was
singing and everything they do a couple
songs and then you go back to eating and
then maybe it might break out again
so you know so not every night maybe
don't don't be worried about a diet
tonight tonight's not the night you will
not want to diet tonight don't be like i
can trust me i can only have the sound
like you need to go eat tonight and
enjoy it a lot of times i leave there
like full like oh god i'm full how many
times have you been there uh under 10
under 10 but over seven
yeah maybe maybe like five to seven five
to seven times not bad yeah
going every year it's every couple of
years you go every couple years just
going every year i know a guy who has a
table as well and he dm's me sometimes
on twitter i wonder if he'll be there
tonight you should go it's a fun
experience you know there's no prices or
nothing
like it's just like is it gonna be is it
gonna hit me they they have this no no
it's it's a it's a regular email you if
you're going with a group first of all
you're probably not paying i don't think
if you're going with a group and like
let's say it was like for you and you
all chipped in with tax and tip and
everything you might go in for a 150
bucks 200 bucks depends how much you
like drink or are they cash only or do
they take credit cards this feels like a
cash only
might be cash only but they got an atm i
don't remember if it's cash only but i
just feel like i feel like it would be
yeah i feel like they don't they don't
want to pay attention you go in
sometimes you wait for your seal a
little bit so you stand by the bar
everyone pounds a drink by the bar
inside inside the bar has like an awning
on it like it's almost like it's outside
it's kind of neat
interesting yeah all right well i'm
gonna go and i'm gonna secretly
tonight's your night tonight's my night
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna wear this
that's a nice uh you've been this i
don't know if i've seen that this well
first of all shout out to roosevelt's rs
oh you told me about that at rsvlts on
instagram this shirt called the kunuflex
best button-down shirt i've ever had
it's getting some now it's getting
warmer got the short sleeves roosevelts
i'm here we just plugged you so send
some stuff send some stuff to sally
babes email gmail pimp and send us all
stuff love it pimp oh pimp would be pimp
legendary in this
legendary in this roosevelt if you're
watching and we know that you are
uh please uh you know hit us up and send
me a selection so
me and actually i went i took the the
staten island ferry the other day with
my family just a random day where we
just said you know what we're just going
to take the ferry me and the fam we just
took the ferry got on the ferry with
just like no destination like we're just
going to go to the other side i love it
and the kids
loved it to be on the boat had they been
on the ferry before never no never oh
they must have went bro raw and
buckwheat power
wrong buck yeah starring starbuck wild
yeah um they went nuts
and we got off the ferry and homeless
pimp doesn't live far from from there we
met homeless pimp we went to this
playground called battery park playscape
it's a public playground
there's a slide
in that playground
that is the tallest slide i've ever seen
in my life like almost to the point this
slide it doesn't look like it's that big
that must be new on the picture
sal when i tell you is it in the castle
it's in that castle thing yeah oh is it
inside that castle thing in battery park
is that where the slide this is like a
open to the public playground where how
long
you know where the carousel is in
battery park that's like seashells
carousel it's like a seashell it's like
you're you sit like inside fish it's
it's it's like a five dollar
you're going past downtown batteries you
can get off the stand you're going
you're walking around you're going past
you're going past bowling green no
you're in battery park you're like
literally in battery cars i must have
not have been there i've been here
it's like where the restaurant is like
the view restaurant or something like
it's like on that so but it's a just a
regular park like it's somebody's local
park and this slot first of all the kids
coming down that slide are going they
might hit a speed of like 15 to 20 miles
an hour
they wipe
each other out because you know a little
kid will will come down the slide and
just be sitting there and then the next
kid's coming by there's nobody up there
to tell them stop go step and they were
wiping each other out we sat there for
five minutes tops
we saw
ten adults go on it like with their kids
eight out of ten when they got to the
middle of the slide
screaming
there was a woman screaming at the
tumblr
and she was like she was an asian woman
screaming and
asian
and then literally
barrel rolled off the bottom of the
slide
she got up her mask was turned this way
had to decide she was wearing a
masculine slide
yeah
she was asian and and and that makes
you go with the demands more prevalent
shout out to the mayor say asian people
go with the mass that's some stuff from
back in the day soros back in the day
asians i would say o.g mass squares asia
all the way i'll tell you day one you
know what a thing i really like about
asian people in the summer months
parasol game is tight
you know they rock parasols wait what's
a power soul
like a umbrella
for the shade from the sun that's called
the parasol yeah you know like you know
like uh bentley what's his name what's
pete did he's butler's name
farnsworth now he holds up like it's
really it's very like french english or
but but but asian people i'm telling you
they got a tight parasol game take
notice of it in the summer months i used
to work with with this young kid he used
to we used to go hang out he used to pop
a parasol all the time
and i really like it
imagine it now it's it's it's basically
umbrellas for rain parasols like sun i
don't know if it's a fashion i think
it's just for shade yeah but you know we
should do parasols right yeah i should
do we should do power i hate the sun
beating down on me when i'm having a
stroll let's make some merch
you want to make powerful merch hey babe
parasols let's make bay parasols i think
those will sell
especially to the asian community images
for parasol do you want the difference
between umbrella and powers yeah
generally an umbrella has a curved
handle to allow for easy grip and
storage a parasol however in latin para
for shelter or shield and soul for sun
is typically constructed from a more
delicate fabric such as lace cotton
cycling and canvas and plastic yeah yeah
they're fancy like they have some of
them have like
yeah that's like that's that's a full
beach umbrella yeah
see there you go parasol so it's that's
like that's like i feel like in the
french quarters they had parasols
so but no but i love a good power if you
ever have the chance it's called battery
park playscape if you ever have the
chance again free open to the public
obviously don't walk in there with no
children if you have your kids take
they'll have a great time but go to the
slide the people the adults sliding down
it was genuinely one of the funniest
things i've ever seen in my life i slid
down the baby slide with my 10 month old
and jasmine has it on camera i was this
close to fully wiping out because you go
so fast it's got to be a liability issue
down there no i cannot delay one
afternoon and you saw you you yourself
almost crashed i wonder how many i
cannot believe that there aren't
paramedics on here or that that's even
open to the public i cannot but the kids
were wiping each other out like bowling
balls that's amazing what is that yeah
the sea glass carousel pimp filmed me on
it i sat and i i sat in the only all of
a move up and down except the one seat i
was in
he didn't move up and down everyone was
having a great time when did this come
to pass when this guy i've never seen it
called the sea glass carousel in battery
park i worked in battery park like
crosstalk battery bar for years yeah
when did it come out
uh i don't know i think it's been there
what is that at night it glows and stuff
we were there in the middle of the day
but yeah it closed at night wiki that
[ __ ] it was great chris was getting
heckled by the people working there yeah
the people were working there were like
heck of me they're like they're like you
you scared to go on the one that moves i
was like my life already goes up and
down and my blood pressure goes up and
down i want to go on the one step down
they're like you [ __ ]
when you said that to that woman she was
like whatever this is really wrong with
you she was like get out of here
dude did you ever continue walking up
the west side highway through battery
park there's like a trail and it goes
through battery park it's like city
and there's buildings on both sides yeah
it's their own world over there dude oh
yeah i've been in battery park city they
have all their own stuff like because
it's got to be contained there's nothing
they're not going to walk into the fidei
district no so they have everything they
got a movie theater over there they got
like a shake shack they got cleaners
they got
cobblers they have everything you need
over there and then it bursts open again
and there's another park that nobody
knows about a lot of people ride their
bikes and roll skate and it opens up on
on the west side highway and i didn't
until i walked i never knew it there's a
whole like there's like a basketball
court yeah
there's a marina yeah and then when you
go past the trade center there's a full
upscale mall and then you keep on going
like there's there's treasures to be
found on that trail when's the last time
you left your house with only intention
is to go for a walk true build you know
about true bill i do and i'll tell you a
real story right now okay okay i
downloaded epics
to watch uh this street tv series called
from i was telling you about okay and it
was a free seven-day trial and then i
also downloaded an apple game that i
played on my television and i forgot
about both of them for like a month two
months and then we did a true bill add
and i remembered to go to my true bill
and put all those in and i cancelled
them all yes right away true bill if you
don't know what it is it's a new app
that helps you identify and stop paying
for subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forgot about on average people
save up to 720 a year with truebill
because companies make subscriptions
harder that's the answer which is f i
hate companies that do that before i
before this i tried to cancel the apple
game for six months
six months i didn't know where to cancel
it and true bill just did it yeah you
just put it in your law you put
everything in and it knows how to do it
yeah and it makes incredibly true bill
makes it incredibly simple it links your
accounts and true bill will cancel your
unwanted subscriptions in one tap and
your true bill concierge is there when
you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to over
two million users have saved over 100
milli
okay a lot of money
i'm telling you guys it's like download
put it in get it once and then that
problem that everyone complains about is
gone don't fall for subscription scams
start
canceling today at
truebuild.com go right now truebill.com
hey babe it can save you thousands of
dollars a year
truebuild.com
hey babe this podcast sponsored by
better help you know what it is i know
what it is better help is
online
therapy yes it is everybody's mental
health is
we all have mental health issues burnout
is a real thing it burnouts when you
feel like you're working too much not
taking enough time for yourself that's
burnout and the people at betterhelp
help you get through it
i
have been on it i talked to my counselor
professional counselor online on zoom
nobody knows about it but me and this
person and it's really been cathartic
for me i cannot recommend you don't have
to do the video if you don't want to you
don't have to do the video i choose to
do but you do not have to can all be
audio that's fine too you could phone
call whatever you want um
and better help it's it's something i
think everybody should be doing it's
cheaper than real therapy and if you're
ever hesitant to to try it out or go
somewhere or or show up or be seen you
could do this from your own home in
complete anonymity you can get a
counselor within 48 hours it's available
all over the place it's and it's just
cheaper it's cheaper than therapy better
help is customized online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours i said all that just
that's off the top of the dome top of
the don't piece hey babe listeners get
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com hey babe try it out guys
as you hear us talk about it all the
time if you've been if you've been
thinking about it take the leap it's
betterhelphelp.com
you don't have a plan you just want to
get out there and go for a walk when's
the last time you truthfully did that
well not in a hotel on the road i'm
talking about from home i'm going for a
walk uh we do it sometimes you just go
for a walk it's yeah yeah
through your neighborhood yeah it's
liberating yeah it's enjoyable nothing's
going for a walk clears your head
literally going i love the home that i
have now my family has uh uh you know
they have the rooms my daughter has a
window everyone's got space i have mice
i
i literally you have mice i have mice
unfortunately get back together it's
whatever it is you know you bring the
mice you know we bring the mice from the
hood so i i
literally though what i don't like about
it is where i live is you you can go for
a walk i thought you're gonna say you
love walking your neighborhood no
there's nothing there's pretty homes to
look at and stuff yeah but i want to i
but i'm realizing the kind of person i
am i don't like to walk in a residential
area i like to walk in a commercial area
that's why i like living in bay
residential is different now i like to
walk in commercial i like to walk past
shops i like to walk in and out of
places not buying anything but the most
relaxing walks i've had is commercial i
like to be around people well if you're
window shopping and taking in a new
neighborhood i guess but i thought when
we remember we went to pittsburgh and we
went to the car we were driving through
the streets and we went up on that hill
you had to piss and you got out and you
pissed in the street i pissed it in the
street yeah yeah but you remember like
that how beautiful that day was and we
just had no agenda we had the windows
down we were slow rolling through the
streets it's amazing i like that i like
when i go on the road i'll get like one
of those bikes like those electric bikes
or whatever i'll rent them or the
scooters and i just get on that [ __ ] and
i go straight to the residential
neighborhoods they just go up and down
the blocks just cause that's where you
really get a feel for what it's like i
like that i think i think it was i must
have been she's going to savannah i'm
going to savannah that's where you're
going to do it
you're going to
get get rent one of those bikes or get
one of those they'd drive you around on
a bike or just walk through all those
side streets up there in the historical
district i'm going to get my steps in in
savannah yeah you get your stepson you
get it everybody gets their steps
there's so much to look at i um
yeah i um i i just was thinking about
this the other day like
there's a thing like i have a little
swing outside my house like a little
porch swing which is nice i sit in that
sometimes just to get air but i realize
like every day if you don't consciously
do it there can be days
this happens to people they don't
breathe and an ounce of fresh air for
days
but it's like i have an outdoor part of
my house i have a front porch and
there's times where like i'll eat like
today i ate breakfast in my kitchen when
it's like it was a beautiful day
why not just sit outside and eat it
breathe in the fresh air because i
didn't think to do it so i'm gonna try
to consciously be like get outside every
day eat outside like enjoy your outdoor
space yeah you got a nice meal outside
in the yard breakfast or dinner what's
better than a meal outside what would
you rather do have a meal outside or
have sex with sydney crawford and your
wife says it's okay
i'm talking about 1997 sydney crawford
top of the world your your your your
your wife your girlfriend at home your
husband home says it is okay it doesn't
count as cheating you can either do this
or have a nice beautiful meal outside
well cindy crawford i will tell you like
almost the entire planet for me was at
the extreme top of my list right as far
as just a gal who knocked my socks off
you know she but this is like it's been
a while but by the way have you seen a
laylee she looks unbelievable yeah
and i would have to say that's an absurd
question
and i think
nine a 10 out of 10
probably 20 out of 10 times i would have
sex with cindy crawford overeating a
nice meal outside yeah
interesting yeah yeah i guess i'd do the
same
i'd
would you like to enjoy a nice meal
outside yes exactly so you're asking me
if i want to be outside eating a meal or
inside cindy crawford
is that that's the name of this episode
name this episode inside cindy crawford
um so on a beautiful a beautiful evening
do you think cindy crawford i don't know
even why i'm mentioning her do you think
like when people say like who's your
favorite basketball player if you say
michael jordan you're like of course
michael jordan that doesn't count give
me a better one you think if you say
who's your favorite supermodel and you
say cindy crawford she's that level like
she's the most iconic supermodel of all
time she's in the conversation she has
to be who is the most iconic supermodel
of all time
like when you say when you say
basketball play it's synonymous with
michael jordan when you say supermodels
that's synonymous with cindy crawford
well in that well when i
90s and whatever it was cindy crawford
it was uh claudia schiffer it was even
evangelistic
i forgot all about her that's from
waynesville and they go
wing yeah claudia schiffer remember that
i don't even know what claudia schiffer
looks like
claudia schiffer do you even know what
claudia schiffer is um uh pimp because
you're younger than us i mean i love
wayne's world
oh claudia schiffer yeah
yeah claudia schiffer and when did she
marry to seal
i think that's who is married to seal i
think that's like wasn't claudia we're
getting knows from the background
giselle it was who was married to seal
tyra banks banks
heidi klum yes yes there they are
i guess heidi klum counts as an iconic
uh supermodel for sure
because the iconic male super mario i'd
say is tyson beckford
or fabio
yeah but tyson was he like an
international monster i think tyson
backfired was international really i
haven't heard of him i went to his um i
went to his chippendale show
completely by myself i was doing the
comedy cellar in las vegas
uh at the time at the rio chippendales
is at the rio tyson beckford was
performing at the rio i had
time to kill didn't know the lineup of
comics one at the at the comedy cellar
there are free tickets to the
chippendales
show
if you're performing at the comedy
seller because it's all in the real you
can get tickets to the chippendale show
so i got the tickets and i went to go
see tyson beckford perform at
chippendales and it was probably one of
the best shows i've ever been at in my
life
i swear to god what happened
it was just him the whole time just
streaming no no no no it's it's these
guys so he's a chippendale or he's a
he's a model i don't understand no tyson
beckford's a model but he's at they have
chippendales does the thing where they
have celebrities come in like vinnie
guadagnino from the jersey shore
is one of the celebrities that comes in
and does the chip and dances and stuff
does a whole show it's great it's great
yeah all right no no no i'm talking
about i saw tyson beckford
for one show i'm not talking about the
only time in the chippendales i'm in
chippendale several
i go
i don't think it's gay no i they put on
a fantastic show a fabulous show one of
my friends we went to when when vinnie
guadagnino was was the because you know
he's friends of ours we went and they
actually brought one of my friends who's
a guy up on stage and they put him in a
rope lasso and they swung him around in
a rope and he said it was fantastic the
guys did it his name is james debo
oh yeah d-box they have good bits yeah
it's they're very athletic
yeah you
i will say the only thing about a
chippendale show is if you're a guy on
the cusp like me meaning
you know i exercise a lot but i i have
good day i have days right
that too
um on the cusp these guys will not make
you feel good because it they are
not an ounce of body fat
absolutely jacked all of them can i ask
you what kind of life is that it's not
fun it's terrible what are they going to
eat at rails
seriously they can't go to rails
if they got invited to rails he they
couldn't go they would drink they would
drink seltzers give me ryoza give me
death that's what i say give me rails or
give me death uh okay i can see that go
into that
yeah
i i we did it on a show what'd you do
yeah we put murray in the thunder down
under dodge
yeah but before we did we he we shaved
his whole body and then injected his
entire body
multiple injections with histamines that
he was allergic to
and then we put him in daisy duke's
in a look look at his back oh my god we
put him in daisy dukes and a cowboy hat
and we put him on stage and his body
look it broke out in highs while he was
dancing
you can find the video here's the thing
with murray every time when i no no it's
definitely on youtube no no when i
played on our show oh
[ __ ] here's the thing with murr if you
gave mer like six months he could he his
body is like he doesn't have that much
work to do because they're all
look look at his back he's worked he's
worked out for um for his whole life
he's never he's never missed time that
was one of the best shapes he was ever
in i don't know if he's in that kind of
look at his body look at his body though
oh my god wait wait do you see look we
had a doctor there injecting him look at
his body
he doesn't look bad but his body is his
body is pussing and festering he
does that that had to suck
what is he allergic to peanuts i don't
remember what it was but we we shot him
with so much of it do you ever think
that there's a time like as time goes on
like murr could come back and sue you
for this well do you guys have to all
sign waivers like we won't show each
other in time for this we don't we've
done such bad stuff same dude yeah it's
like it's there was one time we got a
dentist and he was giving a food
presentation about foods from all around
the world and right before we shot him
up i don't even know if it was legal we
shot him up with so much novocaine in
his mouth that his mouth went like dead
and then he had to go out and and give
this whole speech and he he didn't have
function of his own mouth
oh my god
his whole it looked like he had bell's
palsy his whole face drooped down and
look at his face
this [ __ ] dumb face
wow good for them um
look at this oh hey what's my favorites
when you had him in the mullet for like
a year
yeah you know about that he had a full
mullet for yeah it wasn't his hair
though but it was real human hair cute
it was q's hair so murray we we made q
grow his hair about one foot
okay q wanted to cut his hair when it
got up to like here he was growing along
and then we had an idea
what if we had a professional literally
shave q's hair his head off and make a
wig out of hugh's own human hair and
then
and then murray had to wear it for one
year
anywhere he went in public he wore it on
the show
on the show one full year it didn't get
washed one year did it stink by the end
yeah every single bit we did for a full
season he put on that wig of q's real
human hair oh my god
then we should be like i see like let me
ask you this like something like this
like do you even remember filming this
like do you even remember the moments
about so so i remember this but i look
back and i only remember like like half
of it isn't that wild like crazy like
you literally and it's not that you
don't care because you no it's just you
don't have
your brain can't do like you genuinely
have filmed things for hours and days
and and you don't remember a second of
it second it's it's actually
mind-blowing like things like this like
they'll resonate because it's such a
different thing where is that washington
square park yeah that one is
washington's way yeah
yeah no joke that day we we we were
filming and literally a guy just dropped
his pants at the chess boards and just
[ __ ] right in front of us right in front
and took a full [ __ ] right in front of
us while cameras are rolling cameras are
rolling but you didn't you couldn't use
it we didn't record it he just was like
cameras are rolling not on him but
he just [ __ ] um
yeah i would love to you know the show
will come on sometimes i'm flipping
it'll come on and i look and i go i
i have zero recollection of this moment
this bit what i said oh i could watch it
the way you could watch it i'd be like
no idea sometimes you're even a part of
the punishment and you don't even
remember it punishments
i kind of remember if it's because it's
if it's focused on me a little bit but
still a bit will come up and i'll be
like for a billion dollars i don't know
what what's gonna happen and what i'm
gonna say yeah that's very very very
interesting that that happens because
obviously i'm no it's just like a life
thing where it's like i'm so much at
times like i look back at
pictures or videos of like you know my
my daughters and i'm like
this was like such a iconic moment for
me i don't remember i don't remember
anything about it it's like
i almost feel like because i've spent so
much it could be technology you we cram
so much [ __ ] in our brains with our
phones and ipads and all that that like
sometimes i feel like i'm losing more
mental space but it is true right it is
true that like you i think this is true
that your brain
i mean we don't unlock the power of our
brain but i think that at some point
memories that aren't formed in uh
the cortex like the medulla or whatever
the hell it is the oblongata the medulla
lasagna yeah yeah so like those there's
there's memories that get stored there
initially and those are ones that you'll
remember and then if they don't are they
if they aren't impactful
like they say you won't remember them i
think that there's a therapy or a type
of drug
something that opens up your mind
marijuana i think no
yes but nowhere it's like it's a
specific thing where it's like it
unlocks memories like nothing crazy like
like there's memories you have in your
head from when you were six years old
that aren't unlockable
but this drug when someone is like when
someone can't get to their bitcoin yes
exactly they don't remember the secrets
but it's like this ever happened to you
we're like a memory just out of nowhere
or a person that you didn't even
remember existed
or you see a picture like remember them
yes and sometimes i'll remember the
person's image
and i can't i don't know their name at
all and they were in my life for like
a couple of years yeah and you don't
remember high school kid i went to
school kids for four years you could
show me a picture of a guy i remember
that kid no idea what his name is yeah
no or you could show me a picture of a
kid where it's like i don't even
remember them at all i don't remember
their name or their face at all and it's
crazy crazy crazy because then you know
if that person would feel horrible but
then i'm that person to someone they're
like i don't remember this person zero
the reason that we're feeling it more
now is cause we're getting older because
i remember when i was younger right you
have only a finite amount of memory
because you're let's say you're 20 years
old i would talk to my dad my dad always
came across to me as so forgetful i mean
he can't remember anyone's names and i
would say oh like when did that happen
and he'd be like i don't know how old
were you i don't know what year i don't
know how do you not know he's like i
just don't know and now i'm starting to
understand what he meant what that meant
because it's easier to recall things
when you're 20 and you're just thinking
about the last 20 years you know i've
made a decision and it's it it's a
concrete confirmed decision i haven't
picked the time yet but i am
going to peru and taking ayahuasca
i've made that choice
swear on everything i am going to do it
i think ari i've already most likely
done that right yeah have you talked to
anybody
ari i spoke it too and i support andre
did it too yes but like you know you
could do it in america and all that and
i know there's people out there
it's fine
i want to go permanently is there a risk
you could permanently [ __ ] something up
here's the thing with here's the thing
here's what's happened with these with
these substances psilocybin and ios and
all that is there's been a campaign i
still like that i want to read that fact
about the rain soon ask yourself this
there's been a campaign
you know against all these types of
drugs because it connects you to like a
state of consciousness like you know an
altered state of consciousness that
you know therapeutics allegedly like
unlocks
it
allegedly
babe i had uh
last night two nights ago i had for the
first time in a while i i hadn't i
forgot i was in the cupboard i just
called it a cupboard cupboard i had my
beam dream babe my bean cocoa powder you
told me that i told you coco powder you
get the best sleep
did you get an unbelievable sleepless
night i go right out you know you don't
have me no i remember to take it because
a couple months before i was on the road
and i had a 7 am flight and i had to be
up at like 5 10 in the morning and when
i went to bed the night before like 12
o'clock i can't fall asleep because i'm
so nervous right that i'm not gonna get
up in time i i already have the anxiety
and i i could not sleep to the whole
night i came home i couldn't afford to
not have another night of sleep so i
have my
uh my beam dream cocoa powder which
tastes great right yeah i put it you
could put it in water i put it with a
little hot milk and have they send you
this like automatic like this uh
battery-powered stirrer and you put it
in there it's like
it whips it around hot cocoa i sip it
right before bed delicious dude i go
out and it's it's just cp there's no thc
or anything like that i wake up
completely
or anything not groggy at all i'm
telling you i've already reordered it
like twice
well it says for for being dream 98 of
people surveyed fall asleep faster when
taking bean dream and 99 percent of
people experience better sweep collar sw
sleep quality i say you're on the 98 99
percentile i am dude the worst thing is
getting up in the day when i have a full
day of work and i feel exhausted when i
wake up
and it does it just doesn't doesn't
happen guarantees me deep sleep well
what also is a guarantee if you don't
love it you'll get your money back
guaranteed and for a limited time you're
going to get 20 off when you go to
shopbeam.com hey babe and use the code
hey babe at checkout that's shopbeam.com
hey babe and use code hey babe for 20
off okay all right babe cha-ching
whoop shopify that's the new that's a
new sound that they do i love it
it's the sound of another sale on
shopify that's what i say when i get it
it's the sound of shopify the shopify is
an all-in-one commerce platform to start
run and grow your business it's the
one-stop shop guys if you are starting
an e-commerce business have anything to
sell at all we love it we love our
shopify has the tools and resources that
make it easy for any business to succeed
from down the street to around the globe
it's available everywhere what i love is
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so upstart startups and established
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed they
level the playing field now you can have
access to to this kind of functions that
larger businesses have right out of your
own personal business scaling your
business becomes easier uh like shopify
powers millions of businesses from first
sale to full scale you reach customers
online and across social networks with
an ever-growing suite of channel
integrations and apps including facebook
instagram tick-tock pinterest all the
big dogs are on it synchronize your
online and in-person sales gain insights
as you grow with detailed reporting of
conversion rates profit margins and
beyond more than a store shopify grows
with you this is possibility powered by
shopify so that's it you have all the
tools you need all the resources it
shoots out the statistics it's a
one-stop shop for all your ecommerce
needs go to shopify.com
hey babe uh that's all lowercase on the
hey babe for a free 14-day trial and get
full access to shopify's entire suite of
features grow your business with shopify
today go to shopify.com
hey babe right now what is it
shopify.com hey babe
so
so
but there's been this whole campaign
with the like i have world governments i
guess about like no ayahuasca no
psilocybin it's bad bad bad it's
gateways this or that but then alcohol
they like pump alcohol where alcohol
there's way more deaths with alcohol
than
ayahuasca because alcohol makes you kind
of dumber where ayahuasca opens up parts
of your brain where you can like connect
to a consciousness a higher being a
higher power there are some tribes right
now today in the amazon that give a shot
of ayahuasca to a seconds old baby
because they wanted to connect
to this consciousness immediately so
that's what it is if you're giving
ayahuasca to a seconds old baby
and it's fine i can do it it's this
whole thing about it's like kind of like
um i don't want to say fake news but
it's like there's this whole campaign
against it because everybody who takes
it is like yeah i connected to a higher
power i'm not as nervous i'm not taking
uh i heard that like you even talk about
micro dosing as a form of therapy and
for people yeah so anxiety right right
right but like but is
are the peril are the are the are the
cons are they real or are they you're
saying they're faking they're just
it's not as bad as listen because i
heard like oh you you know you can f
shut up did you ever see someone take a
salvia trip
no on youtube
remember do you know what salvia is
didn't we smoke it in your in your thing
that is definitely sativa sativa yeah so
salvia right is was this thing and i
don't know if it's popular anymore but i
remember when it came out you basically
take it and for like a minute
you go
away
okay so people were putting on their
webcams and taking it on their webcams
and you could watch the trip that they
take because they don't they're not
there they are not there anymore and it
is the most frightening thing i've ever
seen in my life all this and yeah and a
lot of people say it's not good like you
you because in ayahuasca can you do it
and then all of a sudden you're having a
bad trip because if that's the case i
don't want to do it well that i think
that the whole point of going to peru
and doing it with a shaman is you're
doing it with someone who's like an
expert in that field where their whole
life has been like
around this drug okay supposedly because
ayahuasca it's the you know it's dmt is
the active ingredient in ayahuasca and a
lot of which is the spirit molecule what
gets secreted in your brain right before
you die right but they're saying that
like ayahuasca and all those plants it's
what like the ancient egyptians the
ancient native americans all these
people used to eat it was a part of
human culture was like that's why it
grows out of the earth you can connect
to like this spirit world yeah where now
for for the last like 100 years they've
removed that because they're like we
can't have these people at a higher
level at a higher consciousness so that
now listen i'm watching a lot of youtube
documentaries so i don't know what's
real and what's not but
i kind of feel like what do i have to
lose
you know what is it what are these what
are these ones i looked up in the
ayahuasca retreat in peru and i'm just
looking at the ones oh look at the
reviews just bad staying one star one
star stay away
keep going what's the reason they're
saying stay away
keep going just let's just see let's see
the top line
just the top pages of bad reviews pork
poor what did it say but this is
horrible facility under okay but that's
[ __ ] you're worried about that
read them read them the toilets wouldn't
flush
making a money-making scam okay
in my opinion the risk of having a bad
experience far outweighs the possibility
of having a good one yeah but i think
these people are going in with a
negative mindset you have to go with a
positive mindset you think they're nerds
i think they're nerds okay i think that
they're nerds why does that one say
donald trump
exactly so now wait wait sorry
i said i would like right here right
here scroll down a little bit right here
it's in the middle i said i would like
to discuss the situation and took a seat
at his desk where i noticed a donald
trump money success book i was then told
that i invested every cent after a
considerate amount of discussion the
boss teddy said good day packed his
smartphone into his belt pick up his
leather gloves and a llama coat and left
no resolution i still believe ayahuasca
is positive but i think it's important
to find a spiritual company not a suit
and tie kind of place yeah that's what
i'm looking for i'm looking to go to the
mountains of peru also this is from
january 2014 the world's changed now
ayahuasca has come far ayahuasca is
getting better can can you can you put
up uh salvia on youtube and put salvia
trip i don't know if they took those
down but yeah no this is the one we saw
we look at this kid
these are the original impractical
jokers
it's weird audio or that'll get ripped
if you give audio
it will get ripped will they demonetize
us i don't think so look at look at this
guy
he's not conscious
what is he doing he's jumping up and
down
looks like a
like a primate yeah he can't like
control his body which
that's i don't want to do
that i feel like there's not we don't
understand the brain enough to really
take a real stance
yeah
i'm just saying i'm at a point in my
life where i'm comfortable with the rest
she's tried it's great what is he doing
oh yeah no that's on the patreon what
does he think he's doing like you know
what i mean like look at look at what is
actually happening to him how is it why
do it why do it yeah
sativia i don't understand salvia salvia
my name is salvia volcano no but it's
people that take it alone on their
webcam i mean i don't know they smoke it
there's people sober that are terrifying
have you guys ever heard of false
memories where you just convinced
yourself something happened is that like
berenstain bears
but is false memories
is that the butterfly effect what's the
butterfly effect i think it's like like
you start to no really i know that's
something like isn't it like you start
to believe
a ver you
okay i think what it is is there's
something like where your memory is so
far removed that you start having
memories of your last memory so it's
almost like a game of telephone right so
if you're if you're 20 years into a
memory and you're what you're doing is
you're accessing the memory of it so
it's it's one of the reality
right so in your head
the memory your memory of something can
change and your last memory most recent
memory of that thing might be different
than a few memories before it and so
over time you believe something you get
this potential to believe something that
didn't actually happen because it's
morphing in your brain
your brain
to you you're not lying you can look
this person up to a line technical
correct yeah it's real to them but it's
not so it's okay so then what is real i
mean we had this discussion the other
day our eyes and ears perceive
everything on a delay so everything's
already happened
we have a lag naturally yeah how long is
that like i think it's like milliseconds
or something yeah but over the course of
a life you're like
hours behind your life and we also hear
and see in a spectrum so we don't know
if there's like just animals that exist
in a different spectrum well that well
there's well colors is proven there's
like a thousand colors we can't see and
also if you ever look put on those
glasses like spectrum glasses or you
might be able to see it online like
right now in this room there's like
rays everywhere that our eyes just can't
pick up and put on these certain glasses
you can see
like these rays of light that are
shooting in all different directions
can't even imagine what another color
would look like that we haven't seen
yeah or another color or like shapes
like there's like if you look like like
if you i googled once like colors that
don't exist
shapes that don't exist and it's like
what comes up wild [ __ ] it says your
brain may be on a 15 second away what i
mean that's how is that possible no
because we live in this reality so it's
we don't feel it
it's like when your internet starts like
[ __ ] out maybe that's where pimp
maybe that's where like deja vu or or oh
i had a feeling you were going to call
is coming when you think about someone
oh it's called 15 seconds ago and they
called 15 seconds ago you know what's
getting crazy is i was talking to my boy
tank sinatra shout out tank sinatra
and the tank shout out tank and i said
to him he hooked me up with the watch
guys do you want to call him tank i call
him tag no you're doing watches now yeah
i wanted to i don't want to go back to
that mandela effect i wanted to invest
in a watch because watches is a good
investment
and
the money i know you are the most statin
island person and the money and the
money goes up in a watch you know about
watches the investment on watches big
return on watches i do know about
watches some watches at least hold their
value some watches go up because they
become rare pieces exactly look before
we go further how is bitcoin doing
bitcoin is bad
i say now's the time to buy didn't
didn't it didn't uh
all the large cryptocurrency things just
have a meltdown that's what they say
trillion dollars i think that it's the
big guys crash in the market so they can
scoop it up and it's going to come back
in bye bye bye
so well gary vee
says to without a doubt buying a tease
and buy bitcoin right now bitcoin he's
like the people that reject it and say
this is crazy this is that you're just
doing yourself a disservice because
you're you're in denial yeah there's too
much money in it but what the internet
needs a christa stefano finance show
that's what we need i'm gonna go watch
your watch suzy orman
uh
no but i've watched her show i've seen i
know she is yeah she's like he'll tell
you like she used to do this show where
like
people will call and be like hey look
this is what i have in the bank these
are my bills uh this is what i make a
year uh i want to buy you know this
electric bike or i want to buy this
watch should i do it then she just like
rain bands everything and she goes
approved or she goes i'm not letting you
get it
does she doesn't do the show anymore
it's so much fun i used to watch it all
the time so susie orman shout out she
looks like everyone's auntie
what are we doing so no here's the thing
so the watch i was gonna get right now
i'm not sure i'm on the fence but i do
want a um uh rose uh rose gold
you know what i'm talking about i don't
know what it's called
it's like a rose gold watch yeah it's
something like this
um
no diamonds though you don't want to do
diamonds don't diamonds make the value
go down on the watch how's that because
it's just i don't know it just does
somewhere that it's no good you don't
want to do it so it's something where
it's nice i don't know anything about
watches
yeah
so but but my point is is that i'm it's
about the cell phones so we i go to
invest i i'm talking uh i'm you know
tank months ago i was talking he was i
was talking about like what's a good
investment and he was like because
that's where i take my investment uh
advice from tank sinatra so you know
where he's talking about watches and how
he makes money on watches so he was like
i got him
yeah he flips watches so he was like i
got a watch guy
so he hooked me up with the watch guy
we're texting whatever i can't make it i
can't make his you know into the shop
whatever whatever this is two three
months ago i'm with tank last week
me and tank start talking about the
watch guys we're in suffolk county can't
say tank enough in my opinion yeah so me
and tank are talking about the watch guy
don't and that's all i know him as is
the watch guy okay i don't know his name
i don't even know what his name is i
just know him as the watch guy yeah so
we're talking about the watch guy and
he's talking about the watchers whatever
two hours later after i'm talk we're
talking about the watch guy
i haven't talked to him in three months
i get a text from the watch guy i get a
text from the watch and he goes yo when
do you want to come back inside i said
to tank did you text a watch guy he goes
no
i go i haven't talked to him in three
months the watch guy just texts me
you know what i think happened as we
were talking about the watch guy and
watches and some type of in the
algorithm thing on instagram probably
push my feed into his feed got hit me
and his mind again and then he texted me
that's what i think happened just like
one time i saw a friend of mine that i
hadn't seen in 10 years
stopped at a red light in bay ridge all
of a sudden i'm walking two days later
that person's suggestion friends that
you may know pops up on facebook or
instagram or whatever so it's sick with
the algorithms now how you think it's
fate and destiny and all that but it's
really just they put it in your head i
think the internet has been around for
ten thousand years it's just now we have
a way to access it i think they made the
internet ten thousand years ago and it's
just always been here it's just
different we have different way you know
now we have the phone and i think the
town
has always been here how long do you
think it took to download a jpeg in 5000
bc it took forever i think it lifetimes
yeah lifetime can i tell you a crazy
coincidence that happened to me once i
was getting
uh i was at the doctor all right and i
was what are we getting done
well i wasn't it wasn't the doctor it
was the freaking uh imagine like cheek
filled cheek fillers would you ever get
cheek fillers
would i ever yeah 100 okay no never i
don't i mean
um i was uh i was it was i was getting
my shot by vaccination that's where i
was yeah and i was like sitting at you
of course yeah and uh i was
talking to
was that he was like talking oh yeah so
i was talking to the person who met with
me and i brought up
something just ari sophia's dog his name
is bandit okay and i brought up bandit
to the person that was with me and
when i tell you
in in
three three seconds after i said the
name bandit a guy walked by with a zip
up zip up hoodie on and he walked right
past me and stood right here and the
back of his hoodie just said bandit and
i was like that is that i mean what are
they what are the odds of that it only
said one word it wasn't like a company
just said it just said the word bandit
and i took a picture of it and i sent it
down and i was like i said the word
bandit and this guy walked in front of
me two seconds later i i mean i i get
that's just a coincidence but like
what are the odds well it would blow my
mind if it was anything other than the
vaccine appointment because you did have
a microchip in you right so it was
attracting someone like-minded things so
it you said bandit it attracts words
that say bandit that's the property
that's built so that's fair then so
that is wild that is i
i'm starting as i'm getting older to be
believe less and less in deja vu less
and less than coincidence what i think
might have happened here's here's my
hypothesis for that i think maybe at a
peripherally the corner of your eye or
whatever you saw him with the sweatshirt
that said bandit and then that prompted
you to talk about ari shafir and the dog
bandit i it but it wasn't that i know it
wasn't that do you guys believe in
destiny
what do you mean like how so like like
what like like destiny a sense of like
you can't i can't control what's going
to happen in my future you can't control
it no you have a destiny or is it is
there a destiny at all you either feed
negative stuff towards your destiny or
positive stuff
so in other words you're saying you have
a destiny you're going to get to x you
can get there negatively or positively
or you're saying the destination changes
based off how much negative or positive
energy you put towards it
doesn't destiny mean you're destined for
this exact thing
i mean like
you could believe in destiny whether you
can and then you then it's up to you
whether you control your own destiny or
not i've seen that but i mean i don't
know if i believe in destiny
that's that's a bit of a lofty like
that's like some hippy dippy stuff right
wasn't that the motivation of most
humans that occupied the earth their
destiny
before like maybe the 70s
well yeah because they were doing
ayahuasca
so they were connected to the spirit
spiritual power i don't know a destiny's
child
i don't know i don't even know
i think that
i think that
now destiny's child i do think that
there's a uh i want to say an obligation
but i do think the narrative's changing
now with psychedelics like i almost
think like we have to as human beings
connect to the spirit molecule everybody
who connects to through ayahuasca or
whatever except for the ones who have
bad trips i guess but i think it's worth
the risk because if you connect
are you gonna remember it coming out
yeah you remember it
okay how about this i may have said this
already on a podcast but whatever
i
talk to
three different people about their
ayahuasca trip and there was a fact
there was a thing that i read online
that most people say about what happens
when they come out of an iowa scripture
and three different people said the same
thing oh i'm sorry all these people are
saying the same thing they're all
connected through this one feeling they
have and i asked three different people
about their ayahuasca trip never saying
i read people say this
online because i wanted to see if all
three of them
independently said it and they all did
okay and all three of by the way if i
would if this would have been the last
minute of the podcast i should have
saved it because it would have been
perfect to say this has been hey babe
is it over anyway they were like 52.
[ __ ]
we cut that out
that's true
okay redo it
maybe he'll just have sal interrupt with
something but you do want i do want to
know what this is and we do i don't have
to pick it up next time
yeah so we'll pick it up on the okay so
here i'll start i also want next time
can you write down mandela effect yeah
we'll start we'll start off with this
one yeah so okay start from here okay
you're gonna you're gonna get this right
you're gonna know where to cut that i
don't know where the [ __ ] you cut it
okay okay
so
i
i
i i feel like it's fake now yeah i know
whatever just keep all everything and
don't know anything else
just don't edit anything let's just keep
it in
we don't want to lie to you guys what
everybody said and we'll talk about
mandela we're going to start the next
podcast with mandela effect but what
everybody said was
everyone ever
no but it's true we didn't feel good
about it we didn't feel good about it
yeah so we're never going to lie to you
um we want this to be authentic so what
everybody said was though all three
people
independently what they said was
is they all believe that they all are
god
they're all god so they're all god so
god isn't up here or down there or over
there over there i mean
we got a diabetic in the house
so so
so
so uh they're all everybody is god and
that's comfortable you're the center of
your own universe right exactly like
we're all god that is non-ayahuasca
belief too no but it's crazy that they
you are the center of everything that's
the profound thing that they were god my
oh god yeah my and and a person i know
is very close to me night and day
difference pre-ayahuasca post ayahuasca
zero fear of death because what they
also said was all the people said is
they know
they confirm ayahuasca confirms to them
that death is not the end it's just
another part of your existence
that this is just a part of your
existence you don't live in maybe i need
to do ayahuasca
they all con they all believe that i
live every day every single day in in in
in horrible anxiety about death
in general right
mind others everything i i i literally
think about it all the time
so oh my [ __ ] god
i
what time is it [ __ ] i just forgot this
has been hey babe
[Music]
babe um babe hey